الشهادات عالميه بالتاهل التاريخيه لمنتخب
المغرب
وجورجينا تفتح النار على مدرب البرتغال
اردنيه يعود لحضن امه المصريه
عن سعادتهم بالانجاز التاريخي لمنتخب اسود
الاطلس امام نظيره البرتغالي انجاز المغرب
في المونديال دفع المغنيه الكولومبيا
شاكيرا الى تغريد تعبيرا عن فرحتها قائله
حان وقت افريقيا وهي جمله من كلمات
اغنيتها وكواك شهيره التي ادتها خلال
مونديال 2010 بالجنوب افريقيا ولم يتردد
الملياردير الامريكيه لو ماسكه الذي
يتابعه اكثر من 120 مليون شخص في تهنئه
المغاربه بقوله مبروك للمغرب نقلت كلماته
اكثر من
154,000 اعاده تغريد في اقل من ساعه
نبقى في اجواء المونديال لا ف بعدها مشهد
انهيار كريستيانو رونالدو قائد منتخب
البرتغال باكيا بحرقه عقب الخساره من
المغرب هجمت صديقته جورجينا رودريغيز مدرب
الفريق فرناندو سانتوس مؤكده ان قراراته
سيئه لعدم اشراقه رونالدو منذ بدايه
المباراه ووضعه على مقاعد البدلاء حتى
الشوط الثاني بدوره علق المدرب على قراره
هذا مؤكدا عدم ندمه لجلوس رونالدو كبديل
مشيرا الى ان هذه الاستراتيجيه نجحت في
مباراتهم ضد سويسرا
ومن المونديال الى قصه اغرب من الخيال
شغلت منصات التواصل اذا اجتمع اخيرا شمل
شاب اردني بامه المصريه بعد فراق دام
ثلاثه واربعين عاما القصه بدات عندما فقدت
السيد المصريه التي تزوجت من اردني وعاشت
معه في عمان فقدت ابنها الرضيع في عام
1979 بعد ان اوهمها زوجها انه توفي نظرا
لخلافات بينهما وصلت الى الطلاق خشيه
اخذها للابن ومغادره البلاد وبعد مرور
السنوات ناجحه الابن في الوصول الى والدته
بعد ما نشر صوره قديمه لها على صفحه اطفال
مفقودين عبر فيسبوك مرفقه بتدوين كتب فيها
ابنك عايش وبدور عليك ليتدخل مصريون
واردنيون وينجحون بالفعل في ايصال الامن
الى امه بعد ثلاثه واربعين عاما
والى اخبار العائله المالكه البريطانيه
حيث هو احدث وثائقيه هاري وميجا واسعه بعد
اذاعه الحلقات الثلاثه الاولى منه والتي
تسببت في موجه انتخابات كبيره لهم من
الجانبهما رفض الامير هاري وزوجته الممثله
الامريكيه السابقه ميغان ماركل الانتقادات
لمسلسلهم الوثائقيه الجديد الذي يتناول
حياتهما في بيان اصدره المتحدث باسمهما
قال فيه ان الزوجين لم يذكر ابدا ان
الخصوصيه كانت سبب للتخلي عن واجباتهم
الملكيه وكان الزوجان قد كشفت سلسله من
الامور من بينها مضايقات المصورين وتطفل
الصحافه واول تهديد بالقتل تلقته ميغان
اضافه الى معاناه النساء التي يتزوجنا من
افراد العائله
ما في خبرنا الاخير تستعدوا منصه تويتر
لزياده اسعار الاشتراك في خدمتها المدفوعه
تويتر بلو على تطبيق اجهزه ابل وهو ما
يعني تحميل المستخدم تكلفه الحصه التي
تستطيعها ابل من المدفوعات ومن المفترض ان
يتم رفع السعر الى 11 دولارا تمت عمليه
الشراء من خلال التطبيق عبر عبر اجهزه
ايفون وايفون ايباد في حين سيتم تخفيض سعر
الى 800 دولارات اذا ما تم الاشتراك بها
عبر موقع الويب وتحدث تويتر من هذه الخطوه
الى تقليل تاثير اقتطاع ابل لنسبتها التي
تصل الى 30% من كل عمليه دفع تجر داخل
التطبيقات